[Musique]
dans les deux sèvres
cela fait dix ans que vincent touzeau a
repris les 125 hectares de
l'exploitation agricole de son père
c'est un troupeau de vaches laitières
donc il y en a 50 dans le bâtiment donc
ce sont des holstein une race qui a été
sélectionné pour produire du lait
produire du lait une gageur ces
dernières années lorsqu'il s'est
installé cet agriculteur ne s'attendait
pas à traverser de telles zones de
turbulences car personne n'imaginait
alors que les prix du lait pouvait
s'effondrer en quelques saisons on a eu
une ou deux premières années qui sont
bien passées puis deux puis a quand même
le prix du lait qui est trop bas et puis
les céréales aussi qu'ils sont
effondrées depuis un ou deux ans là donc
on essaye de passer le cap même si c'est
quand même quelques sacrifices en termes
de modes de rémunération ça peut être du
décalage d'investissements ça peut être
plein de choses et donc il faut quand
même passer le cap et puis essayer de
trouver des solutions au niveau de
l'exploitation et puis aussi compter sur
des évolutions la politique agricole
après tout c'est un reproche de la
profession en libéralisant les marchés
la politique agricole commune a
fragilisé les exploitations
les producteurs de lait sont ainsi
devenus très vulnérable au cours du
marché
la pac actuelle aussi à s'est
complètement désengagée de la gestion
des marchés et pour nous c'est un
problème qui se traduit aujourd'hui par
la crise dans le lait les prix bas au
niveau des céréales un certain nombre de
deux cycles de prix bas que traverse
d'autres productions d'autres filières
donc ça c'est extrêmement important de
le souligner est qu un des enjeux aussi
de demain c'est que la policière écoles
se réapproprie aussi cette question de
la gestion des marchés de la gestion de
crise
ce sentiment de fragilité des
exploitations il est partagé à l'autre
bout de la france
ici en normandie arnold puech d'alissac
élève des volailles et des vaches la pac
représente 15% de ses revenus soit
environ trente six mille euros versés
par an une somme devenu indispensable
dans la majorité des exploitations
agricoles françaises sur le marché
unique
l'agriculture est devenue ultra
concurrentiel entre producteurs
européens une obsession pour cet éleveur
membre de la fnsea gagner sa vie en
vendant des produits moins cher qu'avant
c'est compliqué c'est très compliqué
donc vont reproduire de plus en plus
avec la réforme prévue pour 2020 ils
s'inquiètent d'une possible
renationalisation de la pac avec des
objectifs de production qui serait fixée
par la france et non au niveau européen
on a très peur d'une trop forte
renationalisation la politique qu'elle
est agricole et commune elle doit être
partagée est la plus proche entre
nous et nos collègues mes vieilles
poules
selon cet éleveur ce sont bien les
exigences environnementales fixées par
la france qui freine le rendement des
agriculteurs ces normes sont perçus
comme tatillonne bureaucratique voir
punitive par une partie de la profession
faisant grimper les coûts elles
empêcheraient les éleveurs français
d'être aussi compétitifs que leurs
concurrents européens
la croissance de la production doit être
souple quand il ya une demande mondiale
en asie extraordinaire et que c'est les
autres pays l'union européenne qui la
font qu'ils répondent à cette demande
mais la france est idiote
[Musique]
depuis plusieurs mois un autre syndicat
agricole planche également sur cette
sixième réforme de la pac
la confédération paysanne prône une
transition vers un autre modèle agricole
abandonnant le productivisme ce jour là
ils sont une dizaine d'agriculteurs
venus plancher au sein d'un groupe de
travail
ici l'objectif est bien de bouleverser
le modèle agricole actuel les besoins de
la société française et européenne
c'est de préserver une ressource
naturelle c'est de rémunérer les
producteurs et surtout et d'abord de
produire une alimentation saine en
quantité suffisante jeunes agriculteurs
fnsea confédération paysanne
chaque camp fourbit actuellement ses
armes l'occasion pour chacun de défendre
sa vision du modèle agricole pour les
générations à venir
[Musique]